in this video I'm going to be reviewing
all the books of a song of ice and fire
by george RR martin that are going to be
no spoilers in this video and if you
post a spoilery comment it will be
flagged and deleted you have been warned
let's keep this a nice spoiler free
place please before I start this review
however I want to talk to you about the
next book club so in this video I'm
talking about the Song of Ice and Fire
which I've obviously read before I am
currently reading
spqr by Mary beard now in six weeks time
I'm going to be uploading the next book
club ish by the way that's not a hard
date in about six weeks time I'm gonna
be uploading my video talking about spqr
and I would love to have your opinion on
what I'm talking about so you have six
weeks go to your nearest book shop or
library get yourself a copy and have a
read this is a book just so you know
about basically I'll cover a history
review of ancient Rome and I've read the
first chapter or so it's very well
written meticulously researched I'm
enjoying it a lot already so if you're
into historical stuff or if perhaps if
you enjoy the game of Thrones check this
one out and I really look forward to you
coming in six weeks time and talking to
me in the comments about what you
thought about this book and disagreeing
with me about my review because it's
probably going to be wrong right let's
go back to the matter at hand shall we
so in this video I'm going to be looking
at this small tree in my hands and
asking the questions are these good
books what did I like about them and
should you read them
so those of you who somehow have not
heard anything about Game of Thrones
this is the first book in a song of ice
and fire the two used pretty
interchangeable E and it's a fantasy
novel fantasy series that is very much
set in the real medieval world as it
were so the period of European history
approximately the 15th century the
events of the book of quite closely
related to the events at the Wars of the
Roses in England which were the 15th
century conflicts about Ross succession
and to start with at least the book is
all about these warring houses and so
the book series is all about these
warring houses vying for control of this
fictional land of Westeros
which is basically Western Europe as the
series goes on however it becomes very
clear that this isn't just Western
medieval Europe there is magic in the
world and as the series goes on there is
more and more magic I almost dropped
have really big spoiler then this is
gonna be hard each chapter of each book
is told from the perspective of a single
character not first person third person
following particular character this
particular chapter is about Arya Starks
perspective on events and as you might
expect from a series that spans over how
many pages I put over here
it's a vast story huge number of
characters it's difficult to keep track
of everyone to the point where the
author actually includes a sort of an
appendix at the back where he goes
through each of the houses who everyone
is and what they do and then at least in
this first book he also includes a
chronology of events and a series of
this length and this kind of setting
lends itself to a comparison to the Lord
of the Rings by JRR tolkien not least
the fact that the authors actually said
the same middle initials I never thought
of that before but where the two books
series differ is in my answer to the
first question about whether these are
good books because to me a book can be
good because it is entertaining it has
an entertaining story it can be good
because it is well-written the prose
itself is gorgeous or it can be good
because it addresses a particular
question in society a pertinent issue
hits nail on the head so to speak now
the law of the Rings is rightly regarded
as a classic in its genre because it
tells a fantastic story it is incredibly
dense and deep on an awful lot of
original thought has gone into it and
for the style of prose that it is I
realize that's not everyone's cup of tea
the law of the Rings is fantastically
written a game of Thrones and the rest
of the Song of Ice and Fire
on the other hand tells a fantastic
story the the events are constantly
engaging because of the length if
nothing else at the series you get very
invested in certain characters and the
characters are told in a very believable
way they are they have they're not
one-dimensional they have a lot of depth
especially some characters Tyrion
Lannister whose particular favorite
character of miner basically everyone
else who reads the books has an awful
lot of death to but where I think the
comparison falls down to the law the
Rings is that the prose just doesn't
match up the prose is it's not simple
but it's not beautiful I think perhaps
the Game of Thrones a suffering because
I recently read in M banks the first
time and the the difference between
these books is they both have fantastic
engaging stories Game of Thrones more so
than consider fleebus but the language
and consider fleebus and the text is
just beautiful but I don't actually mind
the fact that in Game of Thrones it's
not despite the fact that the language
isn't poetic it's very functional and I
actually do like the fact that george RR
martin he does use the full range of the
english language in that he uses a huge
range of curse words i'd be very
interested to see actually how this has
been translated into other languages
because some of the words in English are
choice and I know some people would say
that he over uses them but I like the
fact that yet he makes the use of that
spectrum then he really uses the
language to make you care about
characters and make you hate other
characters basically the prose gets the
story across and the story is why you
read these and full clarity I should
point out I've not actually watched the
TV series I other than season one I
watched the adaptation of season 1 which
is basically this book in ten TV
episodes I'm waiting for my girlfriend
to come back from here abroad before I
can watch the rest of it because it's
very much a couple thing that we do but
the story that's portrayed in these
books is great and that leads me on to
the second question which is what I
enjoyed about a Song of Ice and Fire the
story
the story evolves this is kind of a
consult contained book there's an arc in
the middle of the series which is to do
with various Kings scrabbling I can't
say too much more without being a
horrific spoiler and then after that
there's I guess you could class another
arc which has to do with one queen of
one of the Kings um going a bit mad ours
is so hard without spoiling it that
Queen I've got to say there are very few
characters that I can think of that I've
hated as much as I hated I may as well
say it Cersei its Queen Cersei I
couldn't stand ah when she's properly
losing it um oh my days I really really
hate you Cersei and of course everybody
hates Joffrey Baratheon because yes he's
just I don't know I'm not gonna swear in
these videos but I could use various
curse words to describe him some
characters I do like I'm a big fan of
Tyrion as I already mentioned I'm like
my best friend Jon were both very big
fans of Stannis the Manas King Stannis
Baratheon who has probably the best fan
name apart from possibly Jorah the
Explorer I'm also a fan of I'm quite a
fan of blunt to the point characters
Tyrion isn't exception because he he's a
very sad Worf if you don't anything
about the series and he is kind of
unique in the burden that he's using his
brain rather than physical strength as
basically every other male character in
the series does and not his sexuality as
basically every female character in the
series that's a point to come back to is
that he uses his intellect to try and
get his way through the world him and
another character called Littlefinger
who I don't like as much because he's
not made quite so human he's actually a
little bit creepy to be honest tyrion
tyrion is a favorite but i yes i do like
these characters that are very
to-the-point and brusque so to that line
the Hound is a particular favorite ie
and we use the code word here I really
like the gravedigger hypothesis and I
hope that for the TV series they go for
cleganebowl it's a spoiler that's not a
spoiler you if you don't know anything
about this you don't
that means don't look it up although if
you have read all the books or watched
on TV series there's a great YouTube
channel which I'll put up here called
alt shift X I think which is about Game
of Thrones fan theories that is one of
them a graded hypothesis into a game
Bowl two hypotheses about Game of
Thrones and done yeah if you've read
them go check about access fun in the
same way that I like Tyrion who was
actually quite a tortured character very
well-rounded character but there's
another character called Renard TAS who
again it doesn't fit into these easy
molds of strength and sexuality she she
has her own path in the world and I yeah
I feel for Brienne what you also find is
that as well as these big characters
that make it into the mainstream media
you also get attached to minor
characters in particular I cannot
remember his name there was a Septon
travelling SEPs on a priest in the world
of Westeros who goes on a huge rant -
Brienne actually about war and how it
destroys men and that was a very preachy
part of the book but I actually really
connected with this this priest and his
dog called dog I'm also a fan of strong
Belarus who I don't believe has made it
into the TV series that's another point
actually is that there are quite big
differences between the books and the TV
series I mean obviously if you've
watched the TV series you know the story
but there's an awful lot more going on I
mean when I talk to somebody about the
most recent season season 5 session of
them the season 6 is airing at the
moment when I'm recording this there's
an awful lot of very big plot points
they've been left out the Iron Islands
have not seen as much attention as they
should have done from the sounds of
things so if you like the story that
from the TV series and you like the
world that's been created all right I
don ously say give this a try maybe
don't buy them because they're quite an
investment that quite big cooks go to go
to the library although I'm sure that
every library's copies are on massive
weights at the moment and give it a go I
took about 100 pages maybe 150 pages to
slot into the world and get used to the
language and the violence because that's
another thing to point out these are
very violent books but I got into it and
I became a huge fan when I wasn't
actually expecting - to be honest I kind
of just tried it on a whim and I
I'm very glad I did so if you yeah if
you'd like to sort of fall through the
cracks that the TV series have allowed
to form and see the full picture I can
definitely recommend the books but I
will put a caveat on that at the end of
the video before then I mentioned
earlier about this sort of dichotomy of
power and sexuality between men and
women this wealth
I mean in a way it's almost like a hyped
up version of what we perceive medieval
society to be like and a common
criticism i've heard of a george RR
martin is that he only writes female
characters whose way of getting ahead in
the world is to spread their legs now i
think that there is some truth that
criticism sound characters more than
others but i actually like the way that
george RR martin writes his characters
between the genders in that he writes to
Bertha's awful people basically
everybody in this series is either
impotent and cunning competent and and
just at the mercy of everyone else or
they're like lions and an incredibly
power-hungry and I think the point that
he makes with the women who do get ahead
by by sleeping around is that they are
using the power structures that are
available to them in this world in a
feudal medieval world that is really
ruled by the sword men use the swords
they're the ones that have the physical
strength women physiologically down have
the same strength of men apart from
brain of TAF and so they use whatever
power systems they have at their
disposal
I started their disposal within this
world now I'm very glad that the world
isn't the way that it is in Westeros
because it precludes the possibility of
men using things other than their
strength to get ahead in the world with
the exception of Tyrion which is
possibly why I like him so much and the
possibility of women getting ahead in
the world because of their intellect or
their ability to do things other than
spawn heirs but I think dismissing his
portrayal of women as uniformly bad is a
very simplistic way of viewing things
possibly that is more the case in the TV
series so Amy from the book the women
that he describes our well-rounded
characters
for the most part certainly the big-name
characters people like Queen Cersei you
know III think they are complex
characters that aren't just defined by
their sexuality and but by their sex now
with that said I should probably go back
to the question of what you maybe you
shouldn't read these books the one thing
you shouldn't read these books if you're
squeamish or if you have a problem with
violence incest child murder a lot of
rape actually God when you put it like
this there is a lot of bad stuff in
these things and they were worried about
Harry Potter these are very much books
for adults do you not expect this to be
like the next Harry Potter or His Dark
Materials these are they have very dark
themes and awful lot of very very
especially in the most in the last book
dance Dragons part two one scene in
particular with a character I was going
to name them but that gives it away that
they're alive really creeped me out
really really creeped me out quite apart
from the themes that are you know
Universal across the books it's yeah not
the kids and also not one for people who
are after a light read these are books
that I found I could go to bed and read
it a chapter or two but that's because
of the prose and how easy it is you do
have however to pay attention you can't
expect us to skim through and walk away
and come back and just get on with it
there's very little hand-holding in
terms of the series that George doesn't
make it easy for you
really so you have to be on the ball and
you have to devote a fair bit of your
minds but as a general yes no should I
read these books or not I'd say yes um
with those pretty serious provisos
before I really enjoyed reading them I
cannot wait for the next one the winds
of winter and it's very close to the
whole series being finished hopefully
george RR martin won't die on us because
he's got to finish the winds of winter
and then a dream of spring I think the
last one's going to be cool there's only
two books left but the writer you get
taken on is just huge and some of the
moments in particular I'm just going to
give a shout out to the end of storm
swords part 2 there is a moment where
you see one character's plans
crystallize across the
whole map and it is just incredible I
can
I was on holiday when I was British I
finished the book and I was in France at
the time and I was seriously debating
whether I could get Amazon Prime to
deliver the next one in English to where
I was staying because I just needed to
know what happened next
it is yeah as stories go there a
brilliant story perhaps a little bit
simply told with a lot of violence and
sex along the way but I enjoyed them an
awful lot
now however we come to the part of the
video where you tell me that I'm
entirely wrong so down there in the
comments I want you to fight me I want
you to disagree with what I've said I
want you to talk about his portrayal of
women and maybe differences between the
TV show and the books perhaps why people
should read them and maybe they
shouldn't read them and also who your
favorite characters are because I
imagine that people can have quite
strong opinions on this but please do
comment and if you like this video do
please like it and you can subscribe to
the channel I'm gonna be doing as I said
at the start marry beards SPQR in a
couple of weeks time but yes please do
comment and get engaged with me I'd love
to talk to people about this stuff so
talk to me about Game of Thrones please
I hope you enjoy this thank you very
much for watching and I will be seeing
you in the book club in about six weeks
time somebody commented on the video
where I talked about before about the
fact that they struggle to be in here in
banks because his imagination is so
vivid you have to sit and think a bit
about what he's actually talking about
it just to quickly mention I mean a big
thing that's happened to me recently is
with piano if you didn't see I blogs
that's a that's a use for that wall I'll
put I'll put video stuff up here so yeah
Wednesday Fiona with Tom and protecting
the work great